die virus mutationen schrecken die
politik auf schon am dienstag früher als
geplant gibt es einen neuen bund länder
gipfel die cdu und die frage wer wird
der neue chef der virtuelle
wahlparteitag hat am abend begonnen und
ganz viel schnee der süden es weiß das
sieht schön aus macht aber auch vielen
probleme
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg freitagabend willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick schön dass sie
dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann für
den sport fun junior von mir
die gesamtzahl der korona infizierten in
deutschland hat eine weitere grenze
überschritten mehr als zwei millionen
menschen sind oder waren hier infiziert
und weil sich trotz aller maßnahmen
jeden tag weiterhin zu viele neue
anstecken wollen bund und länder jetzt
offenbar noch mal auf die bremse treten
sie treffen sich schon am dienstag um
das weitere vorgehen zu besprechen
nötig sei es kontakte noch mehr zu
beschränken sagte regierungssprecher zum
beispiel im öffentlichen nahverkehr aber
auch heimarbeit müsse vielmehr genutzt
werden aktuell gemeldet haben die
gesundheitsämter 22 1368 neuinfektionen
binnen eines tages 1000 113 menschen
starben in verbindung mit dem virus aus
berlin andrea maurer
es ist ein schulterschluss von
bundespräsident arbeitgeberpräsident und
gewerkschaftschef der appell an die
bevölkerung bleiben sie zu hause
der appell an die arbeitgeber
ermöglichen sie home office wo immer es
geht
die mutation des virus wie sie in
großbritannien oder südafrika
aufgetreten ist und auch in deutschland
in einzelfällen nachgewiesen wurde
verschärft noch die infektionsgefahr
das macht mir große sorgen wir müssen
auch die kontakte wo irgend möglich am
arbeitsplatz reduzieren
weniger ist mehr gerade in diesen tagen
schon am dienstag wollen
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten mit der kanzlerin
erneut über mögliche verschärfungen
beraten von einem mega lockdown ist die
rede
der vorsitzende der runde widerspricht
glaube man sollte jetzt vorsichtig sein
mit solchen formulierungen und
erwartungen denn wir haben ja auch schon
sehr viel geregelt und ich denke es
macht keinen sinn mehr
weiter zu regeln was hinter
verschlossenen wohnungstüren passiert
sondern wir müssen uns jetzt einfach
auch anderen themen zuwenden wie gehen
wir mit den unternehmen um mit dem thema
office auch mit versammlungen
veranstaltungen im öffentlichen raum die
union dementiert unterdessen
spekulationen dass der öffentliche
nahverkehr komplett eingestellt werden
soll
die opposition fordert mehr transparenz
wir erwarten jetzt informationen für die
öffentlichkeit was ist geplant auf
welcher fakten grundlage sollen diese
entscheidungen getroffen werden und uns
interessiert insbesondere gibt es auch
alternativen einig scheinen sich
kanzleramt und länderchefs vor dem
treffen am dienstag vor allem darin
einen spielraum für öffnung gibt es
derzeit nicht und wir fragen nach bei
unserer hauptstadt korrespondent in
schackenthal banerjee was es von dem
treffen am dienstag zu erwarten
also dass es weitere verschärfungen
geben wird das ist so gut wie sicher und
das hat zwei gründe zum einen gehen die
infektionszahlen nicht so schnell runter
wie sich bund und länder das von den
maßnahmen die jetzt gelten erwartet
haben und zum anderen gibt es da noch
die mutation des corona virus die
momentan in großbritannien und irland
dafür sorgt dass die infektionszahlen
dort enorm in die höhe schießen da ist
die sorge hier in berlin tatsächlich zum
greifen darüber dass diese mutation hier
ankommt und sich dann auch durchsetzt
und auch hier die zahlen weiter hoch
schießen das möchte man unbedingt
vermeiden und das stichwort dabei ist
eben kontakte reduzieren und damit die
gelegenheiten wo das virus weiter
gegeben werden kann
da gibt es viele vorschläge die jetzt
auf dem tisch liegen von bund und
ländern von der ffw zwei masken pflicht
über entzerren im öffentlichen
nahverkehr bis hin zur home office
pflicht letzteres auch deshalb weil man
anhand von bewegungsdaten gesehen hat
dass heute mehr menschen wieder zur
arbeit ins büro fahren als es zum
beispiel im frühjahr der fall war wo
mehr leute zu hause geblieben sind und
heimarbeit gemacht haben es sind jetzt
viele vorschläge die diskutiert werden
müssen nichts steht fest am dienstag
soll darüber beraten werden bis dahin
wird es noch viele gespräche geben
dankeschön für diese informationen aus
berlin giacometti war das für uns gehört
die sorge vor mutationen des virus die
treibt im moment viele um was über diese
mutationen bisher bekannt ist fast julia
schröder zusammen dass cora virus immer
wieder verändert sich sein erbgut ein
natürlicher prozess
die beiden mutationen die nun besonders
im blick sind zeigen vor allem
veränderungen an der äußeren struktur
für das virus bringt das offenbar
vorteile die britische mutante breitet
sich auf der insel rasch aus
modellrechnungen angestellt und die
kommunen stehen in verschiedenen
ansätzen zum schluss dass die rechte
erklärung möglichkeit ist dass die
leichte ein ansteckendes virus kann
schneller viele menschen infizieren und
mehr krankheitsfälle führen zu mehr
patienten auf intensivstationen und zu
mehr todesfällen
ich denke die aktuellen maßnahmen
sollten deutlich effektiver gestaltet
werden und insbesondere auch bereiche
betreffen die aktuell hauptsächlich
ausgespart sind und das betrifft zum
beispiel den arbeitsbereich ein
wichtiges instrument im kampf gegen die
mutationen bleibt das impfen denn das
schützt auch gegen die mutierten viren
doch im moment fehlt es an impfstoff und
hersteller biontech weise reduziert
jetzt auch noch zumindest vorübergehend
seine liefermengen für europa grund sei
der umbau im feierwerk im belgischen
kurs damit sollen längerfristig die
produktionsmengen erhöht werden
weiser sicherte aber zu alle für das
erste quartal vereinbarten dosen zu
liefern
ganz nach plan hat deutschlands erste
geimpfte seniorin in halberstadt in
sachsen-anhalt ihre zweite dosis
erhalten die 101 jährige edith kurz
allem auch den zweiten kicks gelassen
hin die erste impfung vor drei wochen am
zweiten weihnachtsfeiertag habe sie
bestens vertragen jetzt will sie bald
ihre uhr
ja und damit das virus sich tatsächlich
nicht weiter ausbreitet müsste ein
großer teil der bundesbürger sich impfen
lassen und dazu hat matthias fornoff
jetzt neue politbarometer zahlen gut
namen matthias oberbauer genannt wie hat
sich die impfbereitschaft verändert die
bereitschaft sich impfen zu lassen
die hat deutlich zugenommen als wir in
den november danach gefragt haben wollte
sich nur gut jeder zweite impfen lassen
jetzt das sehen wir hier sind es 67
prozent die sagen ja ich werde mich
gegen korona impfen lassen
22 prozent sind noch unsicher und zehn
prozent der befragten lehnen eine
impfung für sich ab die art und weise
wie die impfkampagne in deutschland
gestartet ist sehen die meisten kritisch
eine mehrheit von 58 prozent sagt dass
impfen läuft schlecht noch kurz zur cdu
da wird es morgen auf dem parteitag hoch
spannend wenn die delegierten ihren
neuen parteichef wählen und potenziellen
kanzlerkandidaten
wer von den drei bewerbern hat im moment
die nase vorn
es gibt tatsächlich keinen klaren
favoriten und auch kein klares bild wenn
man sich die zahlen anschaut
bei allen befragten liegen märz laschet
und röttgen fast gleichauf bei den
anhängern der union liegt märz von alle
werte aber sind eher mäßig wer kann
kanzler oder kanzlerin haben wir gefragt
nur markus söder dem csu-chef wird das
mehrheitlich zugetraut den drei
kandidaten für den cdu vorsitz wird es
recht deutlich nicht zugetraut
und wer immer der neue ist er tritt sein
amt an im schatten der amtierenden
kanzlerin dankeschön matthias züge mehr
zum politbarometer gibt es ab 22 uhr mit
matthias fornoff im heute journal
in der zdf- heute- app können sie sich
die grafiken im detail anschauen auch zu
der frage wen die befragten zu den zehn
wichtigsten politikern ziehen wir uns
gehört keiner der drei cdu kandidaten
hat es bislang geschafft sich als klarer
favorit abzusetzen schon jetzt rufen
führende christdemokraten ihre partei
auf sich geschlossen hinter den sieger
zu stellen wer auch immer das dann sein
wird vor einer stunde ging es los mit
dem ersten digitalen
tag der cdu berichtet sie wird zur
stunde verabschiedet annegret kramp
karrenbauer nach etwas mehr als zwei
jahren gibt sie das amt als cdu chefin
ab auf einem komplett digitalen
parteitag
vieles wird neu sein abstimmungen wahlen
wortmeldungen alles ist etwas anders als
gewohnt
anders als gewohnt ist dass die cdu nach
mehr als 20 jahren ab morgen wieder von
einem mann geführt wird
ob merz laschet oder röttgen einen
haushohen favoriten gibt es nicht die
stimmung im eigenen laden abschätzen
auch für parteien derzeit schwierig den
digitalen raum lässt es sich schlecht
mal eben schulter an schulter sprechen
oder einfach mal kurz zu tuscheln wer
was wie denkt dieses gefühl fehlt ein
bisschen die sorge vor hackern ist groß
digitale probeläufe hat die cdu diese
woche schon absolviert und so wird
gewählt 1000 delegierte kommen aus den
landesverbänden der größte ist
nordrhein-westfalen der kleinste bremen
ein delegierter kommt aus brüssel hinzu
die abstimmung erfolgt digital ein neuer
parteivorsitzender ist gewählt wenn er
mehr als 50 prozent der abgegebenen
stimmen bekommt falls das im ersten
wahlgang kein kandidat schafft gibt es
eine stichwahl
der sieger muss dann noch durch
briefwahl bestätigt werden bis der auch
gleich kanzlerkandidat
jetzt haben wir erstmal den digitalen
parteitag vor uns und dann werden wir
einen vorsitzenden wählen und dann gehen
wir in die landtagswahlkämpfe und werden
dann zu gegebener zeit gemeinsam beraten
wer ist der beste kanzlerkandidat aber
jetzt eins nach dem andern drei männer
aus nordrhein westfalen alle über 50
drei juristen katholisch verheiratet die
cdu hat die wahl morgen die umstrittene
gaspipeline nord stream 2 darf schon
jetzt weitergebaut werden und nicht erst
ende mai die zuständige deutsche behörde
genehmigte die arbeiten in der ostsee
die pipeline ist fast fertig nur in
dänischen und deutschen gewässern fehlen
rund 150 kilometer rohrleitung nord
stream 2 soll gas von russland nach
deutschland bringen
die usa sind gegen das projekt
und drohen den baufirmen mit sanktionen
die vereinigten staaten haben mit mehr
als 23 millionen infizierten die
höchsten corona zahlen und der künftige
präsident biden plant mit gigantischen
summen zu helfen
1,9 millionen dollar will beiden
einsätzen und doppelt so viel wie die
hilfen die der kongress gerade erst
beschlossen hat geplant unter anderem
nochmal direktzahlungen von 1400 dollar
pro bürger
die hilfen für die millionen
arbeitslosen sollen ausgeweitet werden
und es soll mehr impfungen und mehr
tests geben
ines trams hat details seit 70 jahren
schon gibt es die bäckerei olivers in
kohler wisconsin
doch die pandemie zwingt besitzerinnen
nun fast in die knie
die so viele kleinunternehmer ein
darlehen hat sie erhalten mehr nicht
wenn ich auf mein konto gucke sage ich
nur oh mein gott wie werde ich überleben
ich habe nicht genug geld um meine
angestellten zu zahlen
nach einem aufruf auf facebook halfen
die nachbarn aus sie kaufen seither nur
noch bei ihr
es ist so überwältigend das bedeutet mir
so viel die hilfe all dieser menschen
der designierte präsident will
verhindern dass menschen wie n auf
private unterstützung angewiesen sind
mit einem hilfspaket von 1,9 billionen
dollar diese krise des tiefen
menschlichen leids ist klar zu erkennen
wir sollten keine zeit verschwenden wir
müssen handeln und zwar jetzt
das ist nicht nur ein wirtschaftliches
gebot sondern eine moralische
verpflichtung millionen amerikaner haben
wegen der pandemie ihren job verloren
unternehmen und kommunen soll nun
millionen dollar erhalten einzelne
hilfsbedürftige 1400 dollar 6 und
zusätzliche arbeitslosenunterstützung
lange schlangen an den impfzentren mit
20 milliarden dollar will beiden das
impfprogramm vorantreiben
bislang warten viele vergeblich auf die
impfung aus wir haben krankenhäuser
angerufen behörden und arztpraxen alle
sagten dass sie sie nicht haben
beiden braucht die zustimmung des
kongresses um mit schulden die millionen
locker zu machen
fraglich ob die republikaner damit
machen es ist seine erste
bewährungsprobe in den niederlanden ist
die gesamte regierung zurückgetreten
ministerpräsident rutte zieht damit die
konsequenz aus einem behörden skandal
tausende eltern waren fälschlicherweise
beschuldigt worden beim bezug von geld
für die kinderbetreuung betrogen zu
haben
sie mussten das geld zurückzahlen viele
gerieten in existenznot
anne gellinek hatte anzuhalten christi
rungen ist eine der mütter die
betreuungsgeld für ihre drei kinder
beantragte und fortan von den
niederländischen behörden als betrügerin
geführt wurde zu unrecht das sozialamt
forderte schon gezahltes geld zurück und
kürzte weitere leistungen ohne zu prüfen
christi drängen verschuldete sich
es hat mich fertiggemacht ich saß zwei
jahre zu hause mit burnout und wusste
nicht mehr was ich tun sollte
es ist ein wunder dass ich noch da
seit 2004 wurden rund 20.000 eltern
kollektiv des betrugs verdächtigt viele
aber nicht alle mit
migrationshintergrund die
grundprinzipien des rechtsstaats seien
verletzt worden befand ein
untersuchungsausschuss der rechtsstaat
muss die bürger gegenüber einer
allmächtigen regierung beschützen und
das ist in diesem fall fürchterlich
schief gedanken
erst gestern hatte der damals zuständige
sozialminister seinen rückzug aus der
politik angekündigt und damit auch
premierminister rote unter druck gesetzt
der seit zehn jahren im amt ist mit dem
rücktritt seiner gesamten vier parteien
koalition versucht der rechtsliberale
rückte nun den schaden auf alle
regierungsparteien zu verteilen
am nachmittag bat er beim
niederländischen könig um seine
entlassung bleibt aber vorerst
geschäftsführend im amt bis zu den
ohnehin angesetzten parlamentswahlen
mitte märz
nach indonesien dort hat ein erdbeben
der stärke 6,2 die insel sulawesi
erschüttert mindestens 42 menschen kamen
ums leben hunderte wurden verletzt
in den trümmern suchen helfer nach
vermissten eine schwierige aufgabe weil
nicht genug technisches gerät vor ort
ist auch krankenhäuser sind eingestürzt
indonesien liegt auf dem sogenannten
pazifischen feuerring er verursacht
immer wieder erdbeben und
vulkanausbrüche in einem der größten
doping prozesse in deutschland ist der
hauptangeklagte der erfurter arzt mag es
zu vier jahren und zehn monaten haft
verurteilt worden
außerdem verhängte das landgericht
münchen ein berufsverbot von drei jahren
der arzt hatte jahre lang blutdoping für
etliche winter und radsportler
organisiert aufgeflogen war das netzwerk
vor zwei jahren bei der nordischen
ski-wm in seefeld ganz viel schnee im
süden deutschlands zum teil mit
lebensgefährlichen begleiterscheinungen
in den bayerischen alpen steigt die
lawinengefahr weiter an
in baden württemberg kam es vielerorts
zum verkehrschaos
eine spaziergängerin starb als ein baum
unter der schneelast zusammenbrach an
abbas
im westallgäu erinnern die straßen im
moment eher an ski pisten autos stecken
im schnee fest und liegen gebliebene lkw
blockieren die straßen fast
ununterbrochen müssen die einsatzkräfte
räumen auch hier in der bodenseeregion
bei friedrichshafen herrscht
verkehrschaos mit staus gesperrten
straßen umgestürzten bäumen und auf
vielen parkplätzen können die menschen
ihre autos nicht mehr finden das sind
die folgen dieses dauerschneefall 40
zentimeter ungefähr neuschnee über nacht
bekommen und auch seit dienstag
insgesamt sind jetzt bei 120 bis 140
wahrscheinlich in höhenlagen sogar bei 1
meter 60 menschen die verwirrung im
schwarzwald besteht deswegen in einigen
gebieten erhöhte lawinengefahr
wintersportler sollten hier besonders
vorsichtig sein aber der schnee
verursacht nicht nur chaos auch
friedlich verschneite winterlandschaften
mit viel sonne wie hier über
donaueschingen
ach wie schön und jetzt der wintersport
passenderweise und da gibt es einen
deutschen doppelerfolg im skeleton in
sankt moritz die fünfmalige
weltmeisterin tina hermann feiert ihren
ersten weltcup saisonsieg und bei den
männern sorgte alexander kastner für
eine faustdicke überraschung
so klingt es
wenn man den ersten weltcupsieg der
karriere feiert auf der legendären
natureisbahn in st moritz gelingt dem 31
jährigen alexander gassner bei seinem
bereits 45 weltcup rennen der erste ganz
große triumph mit einem blitzsauberen
zweiten lauf besiegt er den
top-favoriten aus lettland martins
dukurs gaßner ist am ende eine
hundertstelsekunde schneller
einen schwarzen tag erwischte die
biathlon staffel der männer vor allem
philipp horn als schlussläufer und in
führung liegt ein debakel am schießstand
der 26 jahre alte phillip horn trifft
den oberhof drei mal nicht auch die
zusatz munition ändert nichts daran
aus einer guten chance zum ersten
staffelsieg seit vier jahren wird nach
drei strafrunden schließlich ein
aussichtsloses hinterherrennen das
quartett aus frankreich gewinnt knapp
vor den favorisierten norweger und
italien philipp horn ist als fünfter
vergleichsweise einsam im ziel nach zwei
dritten plätzen kommt die staffel zum
ersten mal in diesem winter nicht aufs
podest der sieger jens geiger hat bei
der nordischen kombination in val die
firme den dritten platz belegt vor
seinen teamkollegen fabian rießle und
eric frenzel der sieger wieder einmal
jahren magnus rieber aus norwegen der
machtkampf in der zerstrittenen spitze
des dfb endet vorläufig unentschieden
präsident fritz keller und sein
generalsekretär friedrich kurz muss
bleiben beide im amt nach einer
sechsstündigen präsidiumssitzung
veröffentlichten sie eine erklärung in
der es heißt sie wollten einen
gemeinsamen versuch unternehmen regeln
und rollen für eine künftige gemeinsame
professionelle zusammenarbeit zu
diskutieren und festzulegen
da schauen wir mal auf der burgfrieden
aufhält berichten
der samstag wird erst sonnig und eisig
dann gibt es am abend nennenswerten
neuschnee mehr dazu gleich von katja
honnefer christian sievers begrüßt sie
um 10 im heute journal
hier übernimmt morgen petra gerster wir
danken für ihr interesse
alles gute ihnen und ein richtig schönes
wochenende wünschen wir auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren das wird eine
richtig eisige nacht im westerzgebirge
im thüringer wald und an den alpen
sinken die werte bis minus zehn grad und
wenn es länger auf klar wird es
vielleicht sogar noch kälter
sonst liegen die tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen minus 1 und minus acht grad es
kann also auf straßen und gehwegen
überall glatt sein auch wenn kaum noch
neuer schnee fällt vielleicht mal hier
so in sachsen oder in bayern häufig ist
es aber auch nur locker bewölkt morgen
früh kann es dann zum beispiel im
berchtesgadener land noch mal einen
schneeschauer geben dann aber wird das
ein ruhiger samstag bevor dann in der
nacht zu sonntag neuer schnee heranzieht
und der erreicht bis zum frühen
sonntagmorgen ungefähr norderney kassel
und münchen morgen aber gibt es erstmal
freundliches wetter sonne und wolken
wechseln sich ab es gibt noch mal letzte
schneeschauer in sachsen oder in bayern
und morgen bleibt es dauerfrost ich fast
überall mit minus 6 bis minus 1 grad nur
ganz im norden und ganz im westen gibt
es zarte plusgrade aber das wird sich
ändern in der neuen woche denn es wird
von westen immer milder am mittwoch
erwarten uns höchsttemperaturen häufig
von zehn oder elf grad dann geht es dem
schnee an den kragen der ja am sonntag
im westen und im süden doch häufig fällt
im nordosten hält sich das kühle
winterwetter bei minus drei bis null
grad
dennoch